[Applause]  dalinar it is imperative that we unite  the nations of roshar this may be hard  for you but it's time to be  a diplomat if anyone can do this it's me  it's a pleasure to meet you oh i'm sorry  i  didn't mean to scare you there i'm here  to propose that  our two nations unite no i i think we're  okay  actually i hear you but what if i told  you the parshendi are going to rise up  and strike again no you waged war on us  for decades  slaughtered our people you personally  murdered my son because he quote  looked funny but what if i told you that  god  is dead no totally understandable  i'll just invade your dreams and  psychologically manipulate you into  agreeing with me  what what  [Music]